we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i think this is a republican caller
explaining
why educated republicans are abandoning
the republican party let's listen
you know it's easy to see why
educated people are abandoning the
republican party it drove
and by the way this is not jimmy from
philly i know the accent is similar this
is not jimmy from philly
david uh it doesn't take a genius to
figure out
that um when john kennedy
asks stacey abrams what a problem is
with voter suppression
he's just assuming that everybody is as
stupid as he is
right he doesn't realize that stupid
smart
people aren't stupid and that
he's a stupid person and so
right stupid people can't call smart
people
stupid and expect them to hang around in
their club
okay stupid right smart people are
sick of being called stupid by
republicans
so obviously they're not going to stay
in the republican party
wow okay i think i get it maybe
uh but what is true is that educated
voters
are leaving the republican party to a
greater degree okay good i think we've
sorted something out maybe but maybe not
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about west virginia giving
hundred dollar savings bonds to young
people who get
vaccinated a florida mcdonald's is now
paying people 50
just to show up for an interview why we
will discuss it
and a man has been charged with
infecting 22 people with
covid after going to the gym and work
with active
symptoms not in the united states could
this happen in the u.s we will discuss
that
and much more and preview tonight's live
stream of joe biden's speech
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow we have the beautiful
coupon code
secret coupon code on our website for
membership discounts
immoral 21 all one word all lower case
immoral 21
sign up i will see you on the bonus show
and then hopefully tonight for the live
stream as well